I I I literally just had like a
dermabrasion facial I'm like oh I timed
this well and now be on camera with
children
fantastic children shot at eye level my
favorite thing
ever I like an aerial crane
shot you guys I have really big shows
this weekend um this Thursday night I'm
going to be in Detroit at the Majestic
Theater and then Friday Saturday um
Chicago I'm going to eat so much pizza
and hot dogs and like drink a pumpkin
cream cold brew I cannot wait to be in
the fall Midwest weather pick apples you
can see me this weekend at the Den
theater and then in a couple weeks
November 2nd I will be in San Jose
November 4th Boston November 5th
Washington DC and then Irvine shortly
after you can get tickets to all these
dates at Esther on i.com I cannot wait
to see you for spooky time hello my
little little sluggy witches Welcome to
our Witch episode I am so excited to
announce I am still on the road you can
come see me in San Jose on November 17th
and 18th at The Improv and you can see
me in Houston Texas at The Improv
December 15th and 16th I have a lot more
dates being added so go to Annie lon.com
an letter.com shows to see them and um
you can see me on annwood every Thursday
and yeah I'm just really excited come to
the meet and greets I like signing your
boobs and your boy boobs so can't wait
to see you there we love better help
here at trash Tuesday and not only are
we happy that this show is sponsored by
betterhelp but you can make your brain
your friend with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com TR Tuesday today to get
10% off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
sltr Tuesday thank you to our sponsor
rocket Money Stop wasting money on
things you don't use cancel your
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
money the Easy Way by going to Rocket
money.com Tuesday that's rocket
money.com trash Tuesday rocket
money.com trash Tuesday rocket money.com
sltr Tuesday one more one rocket
money.com
Tuesday I okay we have Caroline right
here uh I welcome welcome this is our
Witch episode and our resident witch I
feel like I broke into like the dressing
room at the Playboy Mansion that is can
I the bath and then you she actually
works there she shows you where the
bathroom is that's very mean your
Puritan Puritan outfit considering we're
witches well that was supposed to be
mine and then we swi and this was
supposed to be hers and she asked to
switch so this is why I'm in this wait
so you have to like give an excuse why
you look hot you're like I was doing
Esther a favor we were trying to we're
trying to Dumber down this body down a
little bit because I approved that one
so fast you're like K are you okay with
this one I'm like yes 100% easy I love
you so much I've Loved You Forever
obviously from uh Sabrina the Teenage
Witch watch it every day after school
but also when you replaced Ros o' Donald
[__]
what I watched you every day it was like
my favorite to be home sick and watch
you on TV that is that it's such a
strange compliment it's so good it's
actually the first I had mum trous and
disease just so I watch your show did so
nice yeah that was fun it was fun and
horrible all at the same time horrible
it was fun and horrible well it's hard
right it's a lot of stress well David
Letterman was the only person who was
honest with me he goes you're never
going to be as tired in your entire life
as you are you know getting up at like
5:30 in the morning and we were like
live and like Grand Rapids everyone else
we're on at like two in the morning I
always want to say good morning Grand
Rapids that's the only place for coming
to your
live no it it was cool okay but what was
it like to be on literally like a hum
humongous sitcom like when sitcoms were
humongous like Sabrina the Teenage Witch
is like in the moment when you're on
that show are you like I have it all
this is like or were you like this is
stressful have we not spent enough time
to get there I'm so have I ever been in
my life I have it going on the only time
that I really thought like this sounds
really like I lived right down the
street from Paramount so at lunch during
the days of Sabrina I would go home and
swim laps in my pool and I was like this
is the greatest thing in the entire
universe yes that I felt very you could
have green hair so that work we had no
exactly we had no idea while we were
filming it what it was because it was we
never watched it I didn't watch it until
my daughter turned seven and then I
called Melissa and I was like you were
so good it really works I get it now but
but we were just constantly filming
const and then when I wasn't filming I
was on the road so I was just we we
weren't aware of it and then the when it
when it aired I'll never forget I was
walking in the street and New York it
was it it air the anniversary was like
last week when it aired 20 billion years
ago and this group of like 20 kids just
started following me and like screaming
and running after me and I was like I'm
I'm going to be mugged by children and I
don't know what to do I am frightened
and then they were like oh my God we
love the show so we had no we didn't
really get it I get it now because of
how long it's been on and that it's been
on the air every day since like 2000 how
do you feel about the new Sabrina
well I tried to watch it and it scared
the crap out of me same it's scary once
that dream sleep person was the sleep
person nightmare person so and I love
all those people and they and then they
we did an episode and I Love Lucy Davis
she plays ant Hilda and I always call
her 2.0 and she's always like what what
does that mean was there another ant
Hilda so um it was a weird thing how
many seasons did you guys do um I did
144 episodes oh my God oh my God I did
six seasons and then I left to do the
talk show in the season now when you
were like up for that role were you like
I really want this this will change my
life or was it just like a normal this
is your job to audition or you will
understand this ladies I was such a
bratty standup comedian I was like
nothing's going to stop me from doing
the road no I was really like but I
always always in my career I've always
thought like first and foremost true
love standup but I also do love acting
and I like hosting and I like like
there's a lot of things that I I have to
do to feel like creatively fulfilled I
forgot the purses I made you okay sorry
I could not sound more like your we have
to have you back we're going to have you
back because Great Grandma I made you a
person I can't believe I forgot it it's
filled with with candies wor their
original candies like you like now
um I I had been with this guy who was
like really truly a horrible
person he was he was horrible and he had
a bad smell I don't know why I was ever
with him and anyway we had gone to
Hawaii and we had broken up and N scell
who created the show called me and
said Caroline your managers passed on
this six weeks ago but we're casting it
Wednesday we please reconsider and I was
like I don't even know what you're
talking about but they cast they they
passed on your behalf without telling
you why why yeah they never told me they
never they passed they were like oh no
no she'll never do
that I had done a pilot that didn't go
but so anyway they they passed on it and
then they said um I said what's the
character like and I want it to be Zelda
I was like oh no no I want to be the
scientist yeah and they were like no
you're not going to be the sci we can't
even pretend can't be the smart I like
the smart one no you're gonna be the fun
one the story of my entire life and then
um she said anyway this guy broke up
with me and isn't that weird when the
the scumbags break up with you and also
this the bad smell bad like b or
something else okay thanks for the
trigger and um like in a scratch and
sniff it would be poison I it's just and
he had big hairy shoulders we called
them the epilates of fur and he was the
captain of the bear Army those all the
lovely things I he was gross anyway um
he's probably your number one fan on
your on your podcast anyway so she said
to me I go well tell me about this
character and she said well you imprison
a man in your ring for not loving you
and I literally said okay I'll do it
yeah that's
great that was the only reason I needed
and then I went out to Los Angeles and I
tested and tested and tested and then
they were like they're going to send you
to network today and then I just got one
of those weird feelings and I was like
I'm sorry I don't want to do this and I
was at the network and I left and they
were so mad at me and I didn't have the
part yet so I went home and I was like I
just don't feel it and then my mother
was like what is wrong with you and I
like it could be seven years Mommy I
mean I think about it now and I'm like
what an idiot and um and every that's
common and scary because when you do
test for a show they make you sign a
contract even before and and you're like
wait seven years I'm like legally bound
it there is something like intimidating
about that so I get it yeah and I just
thought like I just had always ident I
identified as a comedian and then um so
I went home back to New York and they
were so mad at me and then on Wednesday
they called me and said you have the
part you can have it it's yours you
don't even have to test I love but you
have to go back and read with the sister
will you do that and I was like I'll
think about it did they offer you more
money too you know what I'm telling you
if I can give you any advice any advice
say no as often as you possibly can say
no say no and no and then you're like
the sound of the truck backing up money
is deafening going beep beep I can't
hear you beep yeah was that your first
like big TV roll that was the first one
that really went I did no I did a I did
a I did so many Pilots I did a pilot
called pride and joy and it went on at
the same time as friends and we had like
giant numbers I played um Jeremy piven's
wife and Craig bio and Julie Warner we
were Neighbors in New York City on the
upper west side where I lived and I had
a six-month-old and a 12-year-old and
they had a 6month old and yeah it was
only six episodes so you could have just
been like like Ross and Rachel with with
Jeremy PFF I went in and I I read for
Jennifer Anderson when they didn't have
her oh really yeah because they didn't
have her because she was on another show
that did you show your nipples I think
her nipples got her cast look at that
you know looking back I did not wow
really this is what we're going to do
torture me God look how funny you are
already look at that look at P before
the hair implants I know he has a lot
more hair now which is weird I love
any other like iconic things that you
audition for that um I had so many
auditions for
um what's the Tom Cruz movie that with
um oh yeah sports agent yeah oh mgu
Jerry McGuire I I probably went in for
that five times oh my God you would have
been so good in that to be in the
divorce group I wanted to be Bonnie Hunt
but you know Bonnie Hunt wanted to be
Renee zeler I want you to be Renee Zager
yeah and then Renee zwagger got that
part and then gave Bonnie that part and
then I went in for that I want you to
complete Tom
Cruz I was so you know what's so funny
okay met him this actually I've never
met him okay short yeah very short so
charismatic but shockingly short course
yeah but shockingly short now okay so
during this era I was watching Rosio
Donald's show and then your show
pictures yeah don't make her look at no
really I I I like that little Shirley
Temple black and white head shot that
was cute that was so cute don't bring it
back up do not the fact that my head
shot is black and white is that not
enough and we all have one I one from
John Robert Powers that it's like a
court sketch look how cute that is wait
both of you did John Robert Powers no I
didn't but I have a fourth grade head
shot where it's black and white and I
really needed braces are you a child
actor for like a year in Chicago only
though like commercials and I was a hand
model in the American Girl catalog oh my
God look at your tiny little hands do
you know it's so funny we had this thing
in Canada that was like literally it
looked like a phone book and in the like
late 8s of actors and you would go and
it was their picture and then all their
little you know resume right there and
there were these two twins and you just
saw their hands and it just said
Specialties hand jobs and we thought
that was oh my God I hope it wasn't real
you never know you never know in this
Biz you never know oh my God if men have
foot fetishes why don't they have hand
fetish they probably do I don't think
they do I don't think that's
category well because feet are hidden
away and hands are just that's like not
as taboo okay from the research I've
done which is very minimal and I've
never read a full article in my entire
life and the last book I read the the
tree was just a stump at the end the man
was the boy had turned into an old man
but but um from what I gathered is the
foot fetish is the line from the brain
to the genitals is near the feet the
line to the feet and it kind of getss
swapped what line is this the like nuro
pathway I love the 10-minute caveat you
have to give before you present a fact
guys I do not quote me on this okay I've
never even had the attention span to
read a quote but do not quote me on this
that's why I have this joke I said I was
reading this incredible book well it was
not a book it was an Instagram post but
um I I read all three slides so very
well two of the three I think I don't
know I you get too proud that's the
problem I get too proud of myself when I
read one line like yay and then I go get
ice cream and then I can't do any kind
of meditation tapes either because the
minute a man tells me what to do I fall
asleep I'm like breathing are you not I
have I have like I have a really creepy
man voice too that I do I do Joe
despenza when he's like in space and he
says it really his voice like vibr his
voice kind of like It's upsetting I feel
like we're in a cabin and he's driving
me somewhere I don't know it's it's
spooky it's it's uh you're is you know
who I love he's one of mine Bob Proctor
oh Bob Proctor's good yeah and his voice
is so Canadian and you can do it I love
it it does like cartoon character if I
click on a meditation and it's a man's
voice I instant I need a woman I need a
mommy yeah to relax me right Abraham
hick I'm hard on her right now I don't
understand anything she's saying I don't
get it I don't get it I'll send you good
ones I'll send you good ones Bonnie
McFarland and I just send each other
Abraham Hicks things every
day it is the world of the the meme love
language that's all how I it's the only
way I communicate with my friends well
it is true it's like and then you go and
you see like the whole holistic
psychologist will post something and you
see which one of your friends and you
just see which one of your friends like
to post I one of it's about like friend
ghosting you're like okay I see who
liked this haven't responded to me in a
while she is um the therapist of one of
my friends W and has been for like a
long time is she amazing is your friend
like amazing in love with her obsessed
with her how did you get your
name um I don't know I think um so I was
born in the Philippines but my dad and
his family spent a long time in Egypt
and he spoke Arabic even though he was
an Egyptian he was French and so the
kala is
Arabic it's like a play on kalila I
think wait when you say it like that I'm
like it's a little bit Jewish kala my
God it'sa stop getting her little
circumcised vagina wet she's Jewish
everybody I am by way I also think I'm
Jewish her little penis is getting
harda for eight years you did did yes I
did I had the I went to the center and I
got the thing and okay one time I I
drove out to LA from I lived in Santa Fe
and I drove out in my Camry and I feel
like we're playing a word
game in my head
remember was it Camry your first car too
the 1993 Camry yeah Camry was my my
first car 2001 way oh my God 1984 Chevy
chevet
wow I'm a 1983 um
Hyundai I don't know what what type of
car it'd be but you um what does kalila
mean um I don't know you what's the
meaning of like like khil Khalil or
Khalil Jabron you've heard of that right
the author course yeah it's it's but
instead of Khalil it's khalila they you
it's like a Divine friend or something
like that they saw your shoulders
they're like we got to give our
masculine name you know if I have a baby
should I actually should name my baby
kala one because it's Jewish and two I
already have the tattoo it won't go away
to try to justify the tattoo this
psychopath why is her name tattooed on
you cuz she's mentally ill because I got
a temp what I thought was a temporary
tattoo and I was lied to she got it for
her birthday like that's going to make
her feel good that she got her this
surprise she was like I bet you were
surprised absolutely she barely reacted
too how sad is that she was like
oh tat no tattoos no tattoos nipples
pierc I have some empty holes in my
nipples oh yeah we've um she's put her
big Hoops through yeah when I was 14
14 I was watching Sabrina I was inspired
oh my God my daughter's 14 if she
ever that's my joke I said I was going
up with this guy you know who the person
is because he loves you um I said I was
going with this guy but he ended up
leaving me for this woman who had a
pierced nipple ring because he thought
it was so sexy so I got a clip on and
now I never lose my
keys well my mom when I first got my
nipple pierced my mom set me up with
like she obviously didn't like it but
then she like to your mom know I told
her in an
argument I was like I taking the car and
piercing my nipple [__] you I had my
nipple pierced I I have sex and I smoke
weed and I drank I screamed it all at
what age did you say that 14 wait you
had sex know my was 14 right sorry sorry
this is but there is she GNA come out is
this some kind of a horrible like um
intervention now my's so not that girl
sorry I was that girl you were that girl
well my mom was trying to be cool she's
like go hang out with the boys okay how
old were you when you had sex for the
first time
14 I know not good on a water bed 16 on
the water bed that's the worst it's like
yeah someone to count you in a five six
seven course I had to do it to the
Chorus Line a chus I know there's better
Rhythm oh my God she's got musical
theater jeans I blame the water bed why
rhythms off any musical I lived in New
York we went to musicals every month all
the Andrew Chelle just yeah you know
Andrew's one of the people in Hamilton
he just sent me a text because he's
doing a new musical Richard kind was at
my house yesterday name drop no drop
names I like the biggest fan of name
love name but then there's lame dropping
when it's not a good name like did a
movie with David Hasselhoff lame Dr No I
those ones are like I mean they they're
going to get mad at me for bringing it
up but I do know Nickelback and I will
say it again and again like please stop
bringing it up and I'm like why wait
there when you say Pap Nickelback my
heart swells for you I'm really proud of
you the lumir are cool and so listen
Nickelback I love you I love you in a
real way now uhhuh
can SC Creed is next I'm on my way to
Creed but he's religious I feel like
it's not going to be for me I won't tell
you how it was a terrible story okay no
not about him but it's too sad for your
happy upbeat which we love a sad too
Kila we love a sad Kila writes
depressing
poetry writes depressing poetry well she
did inol came with the name I mean
sometimes she us and we fall asleep
yeah your mother fed you truth STM and I
love you it's a problem people are mad
at
me I'm in trouble all the
time it's a constant battle I'm like do
I be myself or have a
career what do I do I could just be
myself have an amazing career I know cuz
I'm shutting you know what I love I love
how much you are confident on stage how
mean I am to Mark Mar and you like to oh
of course I love that are you crazy
feels so good to just oh my God I feel
like I've handed you the Baton please he
likes it too I just know how much he lik
oh he loves you he's such I see him and
he's like yeah she gives me
[__] I believe it was his birthday this
week yes he turned 60 oh my my God how
is that possible he turned 60 yeah first
of all it's pronounced 4020 don't 4020
turned 4020 I that it's 4020 Vision it's
say 420 you give him for his birthday I
just texted him I love you I didn't even
put a mean comment in I just seism
something very nice what was it it's the
third it's soon right I only saw because
paully Shore posted about it I'm glad he
posted I would have I cannot believe
Mark Marin is 60 you don't understand
how mean he was when I evil met him he
was he was mean to you oh my God he was
negging you he wanted to kiss you no no
we were so yes he was negging me I
discovered that word from my daughter
uhhuh no he was so mean to me and I was
like this prissy little wasp I had no
idea I didn't even know what a wasp was
and they were like you're a wasp I'm
like I buzz buzz buzz yeah and I was 24
and I met him and he had this like and
first he was constantly smoking and I
stupid glasses he was actually very like
yeah and he was so mean and he was so
like who are you and blah blah blah and
then we'd like go make out in the car
for three hours we were we that's how he
knows how to get like I was like G
you're disgusting I can't resist you
that yeah it was terrible I never hooked
up with him but I did go on a road with
him once and he like pushed me off the
elev he like like he like shoved me off
the elevator I was like oh my God and it
was like such a good move but I was like
I'm not falling for this but it was like
you know what I mean it was like just a
little sh I actually okay so in The
Green Room at The Comedy Store in The
Green Room there's footage of this in
the Green Room at The Comedy Store I I
filmed us slapping each other the night
before Will Smith slapped Chris Rock it
was so crazy we have a weird thing where
we predict things like we we predicted
should we acknowledge the Joshua Jackson
breakup we discussed Joshua Jackson last
week on the p on the podcast and he's
now divorced
from he was still with Diane Krueger
he's been with another woman since how
do you feel about Taylor Swift and this
boy this man it's fun look I I am was
like really sad when jelle and Tom Brady
broke up because I was like what do I
have what skin do I have in this game
now wa what skin did you have I like to
talk to my my fiance and like Josh
Potter and be like do you think he's
thinking about Jazelle right now I
thought you were gonna do you think he's
thinking about me right now do you think
now that she's gone do you think it's
okay if I hook up with Tom Brady no Kila
would be the one I'm the one we send
Kila tar
yeah but he has a type Kil what's your
birthday I'm a
Scorpio you could sting
up sing up those athletes you know my
joke I told you I had to have an
emergency C-section because I was very
high risk for having a
Scorpio and I didn't want my daughter
born that good at sex and unable to
forgive this show is sponsored by
better um I'll say this if I didn't have
better
help I don't think I would have made it
here I don't think I would have either
if you didn't have it therapy is really
important and like as a 35 yearold adult
woman I can tell you I wouldn't have
even made it this far in life without
getting my thoughts out without sharing
them and expressing myself and getting
out of my own head and thinking like the
anxiety Loops in circles would solve
anything they don't because truly your
brain does get in the way of yourself
and for me what I love about better help
is you can switch therapists anytime
which is such a luxury if you've ever
had to do it any other way especially if
you're like a people pleaser like you C
like oh my God you don't have to do the
official breakup with your therapist I
love their Journal feature where I can
write down my thoughts in between my
appointments I love that I don't have to
find parking to see my therapist that I
can just switch my phone on someone
there mind it's so flexible I wish that
we had had this when I was younger and
you guys can make your brain your friend
with better help visit betterhelp.com TR
Tuesday today to get 10% off your first
month that's better health
hp.com TR
Tuesday don't we all have subscriptions
we've forgotten to cancel yes let me
tell you about one I just signed up for
uh and have forgotten to delete I did a
little bald app on Esther to make her
look like Casper do you know Bal app no
there's a bald app yes you should check
your tags baby girl I downloaded a bald
app it's one of those ones that's like
3.99 a week if you don't delete it
you're so lucky we have rocket money cuz
your little whims yeah are going to send
you to bankruptcy and you should see
yourself bald it's pretty hard I
definitely never want to rock and is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place it is
crazy that they can actually help you
negotiate your bills to be up to 20%
lower like I feel like everyone needs
that in their life and Rocket money is a
like an actual resource like if you
don't have that Jewish grandfather to do
it for you you need rocket money and
Esther's busy she doesn't have time I'm
I'm booked okay I'm booked solid full
dance cards full we want you to stop um
stop wasting money on things you don't
use cancel your unwanted subscriptions
and manage your money the easy way by
going to Rocket money.com Tuesday that's
rocket money.com Tuesday rocket
money.com TR Tuesday it is so helpful I
am an overs spender I need the money
wherever I can get
it so I was at skang Fest this last
weekend and Joe Roa is the code skang
Fest is like a it's like a for the track
of Comedy um Festival it's like just
just the lowest vibration like we just
rocked out was [__] low Vibes credit
for for knowing it's just like I mean
it's called skang Fest it's weird I was
there but it's so I love being there
it's like I fit in I don't want to fit
in obviously was in Off the
Strip yeah and um I don't think of you
that way okay but go ahead no but I I
can't help it's like I started comedy in
New York with these guys it's like I
can't it's like I love them but Joe D
Roa um he hooked up with a trans woman
on a podcast he jerked her off and she
blew him to completion on a podcast on a
podcast like they went into a separate
room but I and I keep telling people
that he actually blew her because I just
want to up it a little bit like I just
wanted it to be a little bit crazier but
um they that's what they want that's
what they want this is what I realized
all the guys were so happy for him and
kind of jealous like he was like the
king of skang Fest this happened at noon
the first day of skankfest okay I've
never seen I just brought you guys cute
little hat
that was it that I feel but I'm just
saying I think the male Comics I
identify as a witch just so I think the
male Comics want that's what they want
they want they want like a girl that's
not really that has a penis yeah I think
that's like the biggest turn on for men
I think I think it's for I don't know if
it's for all men but I think it's 100%
for all male Comics wait Caroline where
can people get these um they can get
them on I identify as a
witch that's what it is identify as a
witch home okay just that's what I'm
bringing to the table today as opposed
to Annie's story about you guys was
legendary you know du stand up drank his
own pee it was wild I haven't heard
anyone out a boyfriend drank his own pee
because it said he said that it was a
cure for baldness and I immediately
broke up with him I and he's like why
and I'm like well every time you go to
the bathroom we won't be able to trust
you what are you doing in there you're
drinking I know you're drinking like I
can't I can't do it at all guys we had
so much fun with Caroline Ray who was so
nice to join us can we have you back
immediately yeah Sor I get to interview
any of you which is what my normal Aries
nature would be there's so many
questions I have for you now that you
like slip in the Bobby Le thing my
birthday is April 13th oh what is an
Aries are you fire air yeah I'm fire
like okay so my mother was cancer at
love Mother my my Pisces totally best
friend you scare the crap out of me and
I am but as a man my my nephew is a
Scorpio Scorpio women are you're you're
tricky beasts aren't Scorpio men
too yes have you ever dated one never
I'm always like I'm like drawn to
Tauruses we need to get her and another
SC a cage together like the last three
boys um have been Tauruses all like a
day apart birthday really what did they
all
do for a living yeah um you know like
blue collar stuff okay I have I always
dat go for that no you really want you
want you want men with skills yeah yeah
you actors don't have any skills but you
want someone who could like done
literally change a light bulb you're
like or like rewire something that's no
actors have a skill it's lying yes is
they're great Liars it's like they're
skilled they're professional Liars yeah
they're giant pagies yeah Esther you're
an actress no no comment but I do agree
I will never date a male actor and
whenever I see my fiance on camera I get
really betrayed it's a Nick I don't like
he's behind though he's an actor he's a
writer but like he'll pop up on things
sometimes he's really good what's his um
you cannot say that no he's a very bad
actor we never want to see him on camera
again my daughter is Scorpio rising and
she said to me because I had people over
and she goes mommy um who do I have to
be nice to again and I said you have to
be nice to everyone and she goes that's
not what I agreed to when I came on this
Earth I didn't ask to be here I'm
certainly not going to be your friends
we need to let her go no and it's going
to take 15 minutes to get out of your no
I mean it's going to I'm going to look a
thousand I'm GNA press the quad Flex
Jesus girl look at you you guys go see
Caroline on tour get yourself a witch
hat we love her thank you Caroline we
love you so much back come back to
us wait I have a question for you guys
when you have a difficult breakup do you
overeat or do you undereat under it kind
of depends on the level so it's like if
it's really bad then I'm undereating but
if it's just like not that bad but sucks
I that's not that bad cuz I know you
never break up with people you wait to
be broken up with yes correct so it's
like just like a leech just leeches on
until they pull her off you know what
I'm talking about you've had breakups
where you're like devastated crying
can't get up can't move yes but haven't
you also had ones where it's like those
ones I work out I eat well and work out
because I'm I'm having like I already
feel like in the new chapter no those
ones I'm like party on like I don't have
a boyfriend to watch me eat six bowls of
cereal I'm going for it like I'm free
I'm free baby I'm stopping at the gas
station on the way home have you ever
had a boyfriend restrict you from eating
no oh my God I have but like
self-imposed where I don't want to eat
in front of them I dated a boy who would
police everything I ate and this was
like Peak athleticism but he would look
at what I was eating and or better yet
he would ration my food out for dinner
that kind of sounds good and then when I
would intentionally be like I'm I'm
doing dishes just so I could eat like
the scraps off the bones because I was
still so hungry I no basically I've just
dated just obese I've dated eaters um
I'm trying to think if I dated a guy
that like ate healthy ever I don't think
so I kind of dated a guy like a little
bit who was who would like eat healthy
when he could dating a Jim brro is the
worst I'm telling you boiled chicken
boy is a kind of torture that I don't
wish on yeah where it's like they can't
have seasoning it's like food's just not
it's just about like it's not just them
right they are patrolling and policing
everything you do well because they're
scared I have that with I have that with
Todd because Todd eats like McDonald's
every day Todd's trying to like gain 11
years in health to catch up with me you
mean he's trying to get 11 years try
biologically older yes he's trying to
just by hurting his body by being just
terrible to himself um but Todd I have
to like allow him to eat like he I
usually just let him get whatever he
wants but it's it is I have to just
never eat anything he get have I told
you guys the story about in the first
month of me and Dave dating I was at his
apartment and he was going to go get a
Subway and he took my order and I got a
foot long and he came back with a foot
long for me and a 6 in for himself and I
was like you can't do that that's not
okay it was so dark I was really upset I
think that is your partner's job to do
everything in solidarity like if I'm
fasting you're fasting if I'm pigging
out you better jump on this wagon I will
tell you this is my first actual healthy
relationship and we don't do that and it
is better he's Dave is so healthy that
he would never even think to do
something like that to like yeah because
he's not codependent and he's a sane
person so he's like and he has
boundaries no way but if I I insist it's
like I'm not going down without you
we're going down together well it is
it's a good exercise for me and
restraint when Todd has all this food
around he did like he has like a whole
song now he sings When I allow him to
eat pizza he has like there's a whole
routine about me letting Pizza I a video
of it's pretty cute that will be going
online next Sunday you guys what do we
at this stage in our lives do we miss
Caroline yes yes do we what what level
of Halloween celebration is like allowed
like can we could we Tri or- treat if we
wanted to could we go to a crazy party
like what's the right being parent age
without a kid Trigg or-treating is dark
totally I've been there and very
dangerous actually my friend went um was
going to a celebrity a dead celebrity
party where you had to dress like a dead
celebrity and he instead of doing a dead
C he was gonna he his plan was he was
going to go as Luke Wilson because he
had just tried to commit suicide but
then he was like all right it doesn't
really follow the rules he was going to
put like a big nose on and have like the
wristband wait did Luke Wilson really do
that or was that just Ro it was Owen
Wilson sorry Owen Wilson Excuse Me Owen
Wilson he was going to go as Owen Wilson
and then he decided okay he didn't
actually die have to follow the rules
and he went to someone else and he went
there and Luke Wilson was there he would
have seen Luke Wilson dressed as his
brother who just went through a horrible
thing oh my God he he was saved by like
a moment I mean that is so cuz it's an
evil costume so evil that's an evil evil
C was his party in La of course that's
why like in LA it's just it's not safe
this is why I want to be in a small town
I don't want to run into any famous
people try that in a small town what's
that how's that song go I don't know but
I like it oh it's a Sam Hunt song it's
everyone got mad because it's basically
him like it's very bad is it the Sam
Hunt is a country song yeah you're
breaking up in a small town he's like
he's like I don't know who it is it's
this guy who goes try that in a small
town and then basically stands in front
of like really racist places it's oh
wait yeah that's not Sam Hunt I think
our all of us are at a life stage where
the exact appropriate Halloween behavior
is putting the lights on and sitting at
home and giving out candy well I mean we
are grown-ups in costumes right now for
no reason so I don't know what you're
talking about we've kind of made Co
costumes a part of our career
for no reason at all I think this year
I'm committing to C to I want to be the
weird who's giving the candy out you
never done that before no I always give
candy there's an epic there's an epic
scene in terrifier 2 my favorite movie
where art the clown kills this girl and
then you see him go after her mother
okay and it's an amazing death scene you
see and then you don't see what happens
to the mother until Art Is Now giving
out candy to the kids in her head the
candy's in her head wow it's so good
Damian Le only my boy sick man did you
guys ever have houses where it was like
take one and it was like an unsupervised
bowl and you couldn't control yourself
oh and especially if they put the big
candy bars on I'm like oh oh okay I
always respected those homes more than
the my the way my stepdad does it cuz I
go to my my parents neighborhood is like
the number one place to be in La for
kids like thousand yeah thousand will
you take us yes Tom H and some of the
houses in his neighborhood they have
they they're set up as like haunted
houses that the kids can go to like
while it pass out while they get the
candy but he's very strict it's two and
two candy only he counts it up like he
he does math in his head so when I go
help him and I give three he freaks the
[__] out on me and I don't understand it
is it because he wants to make sure all
the kids in the neighborhood get some or
is it because he doesn't want to
overfeed them or is it because he wants
to teach no Rhyme or Reason it's just
two is the number in his head and he's
sticking to it that's nice it's nicer
than one yeah but two it's like also
like who gives a [__] I'm just grabbing
and and to whoever I'm not counting I
like to throw it up and have them try to
catch it I Make It Rain I throw it at
him
I want them to be scared running away
but it's good candy I think F rare I
just I get one of those locy things of f
a teach pop one you guys something
really scary happened to me since we're
we were Halloween themed um you know how
like I dive and I do all that like yeah
and I come across sharks like often and
I never really have an encounter with
them where that's like super dangerous
right I had my first really scary did
you punch it in the face near shark
I don't want to tell you cuz I feel like
I I want to know it did youch the face I
had shot fish and I was gutting and
scaling and cleaning the fish on the
shore like literally Mur I murdered fish
knee high water no KN the shark came
almost Beed itself not those legs even
the [__] sand I never thought that
the shark would come in that [__]
close and it did and it tried to go for
my fish cuz you had blood I yeah I was
basically chumming the water but all I'm
saying is this shark was huge and it
came that close to shore like I'm
telling you I had water up until here
how did you did you just run or no the
girl a a lady who was sitting on the
beach she was like hey there's like a a
shark kind of like inching closer and
I'm like that's not going to come this
close and it did so she basically saved
my life have you ever been under the
water and like there's you like see a
shark like underw nine out of 10 of my
Dives all the time but they they don't
really do anything they mind their own
business they'll look at you and then
they'll kind of swim away I'm so jealous
I want to be scared of a shark but this
was the first time I was like oh [__]
you did it feel good afterwards though
like you got through honestly like it it
was like a rebirth it was it was a
rebirth but also I'm like oh I'm
actually scared now like I'm scared of
shallow water yeah I hate that it was
shallow water I hate that I'm like well
those legs are looking good I can
understand why Shar I mean they look
crazy good when you walked up I can't
believe really how did she get hotter
you're not allowed to have low
self-esteem anymore I'll kill you I
don't okay I think I'm gorgeous should
we talk about our costumes
yes
so Annie Annie what are you I was
supposed to be the wicked witch from
Wicked but I'm not painting my face
green you do know that the wicked witch
is not from Wicked and it's from The
Wizard of Oz I'm supposed to be no I
don't know it and I don't care Esther I
actually pride myself in not knowing a
goddamn thing about it the only thing I
know about is Ariana Grande hooked up
with SpongeBob that's all I know about
Wicked and that's all I care about okay
I'm impressed I'm impressed I'm not one
of
you do you know Nicole Parker from Mad
TV she was wicked forever she had to
paint herself her face green like every
day she was in Wicked yeah that was her
she was a green witch was she the one
that was also in
um was she in
uh Gilmore Girls I don't know she asian
half asian I don't know
wait
wow do you think I could be a witch yes
and wicked as a
munchkin I could be Fiero I know there
were munchkins wait Esther why did we
switch
outfits what the [__] [__] why do you
have to cuz I really wanted that one I
bet you did and I said we could both be
this outfit and you said you're like no
it's fine
I am not I'm a little too bloated to
wear a mini skirt copy I get that and
sometimes that's just like your lot in
life do you know how embarrassing it
would be if you were in in a Min skirt
and she was also in a Min next to why
cuz you've been doing something with the
inner thighs that's different than I've
seen the inner thighs specifically
they're very strong they're very strong
can you kind of stand up and show the
just do it where when she was walking
over
my inner thighs yes they're very is that
all from swimming no scooch to the
towards your camera I want to see the
whole thing o bend over now turn and
bend look at the legs when she walks
really you guys oh my god I've never
seen anyone like you in person where's
the skirt yeah I've never seen someone
like you in real life where's the skirt
from um uh Katie got it for me I'm not
sure amazon.com oh amazon.com Jeff Jeff
Bezos Daddy from daddyy got me the skirt
and this is exactly how he wanted it to
be worn so this is um I'm supposed to be
um one of the girls from the craft right
so I'm a craft witch and Esther Salem
what Salem witch Salem win you burn at
the I'm so sorry but like I feel really
great in this like I look good I look
like me I think that you're best when
you're hiding some goodies oh I think
like you hideing some goodies and people
are like oh my God is she hiding some
Goods under there you like like the the
glisten come like this the light
glistens off like your rack and oh my
what's going on good does she have some
is she hiding her trick-or treats under
her her trick-or teeths but like don't I
look better in this like kilo would look
like a it would be very disgusting if
kilo was in this it porn porn in a bad
way this would look porn on you too
though this is the thing you both would
look very porn swap in a in bad ways I
don't know if it's bad I like a like a
slap and Witch Trials or a a salami
Witch Trials I'm trying to think of what
the porn name would be what um salami
Sal
which I really would like to go to Salem
that does feel like maybe we do a Salem
episode The it it should have been today
Hawaii to Salem the two places in this
country that I really want to go are
Salem and graceand I want to go to
Dollywood but people say it's
underwhelming is that have you been I
imagine I really enjoyed Dollywood oh
wait really yeah but I love her I just
feel I would meet her we'd ride the
rides together what can you do there is
it it's rides it's rides I mean it's
basically like a like a theme park gr
would be fun too though like gracein
would be so much fun wait I have a
question for you guys this was a
hypothetical that um someone talked
about on Tik Tok but let's suppose you
were a doctor or a nurse and um who was
going to win this
[Laughter]
one okay let's suppose you're a
doctor okay I would be so pissed if I
showed up and you were my doctor and
you're at a bar you're at a bar okay oh
I'm a drinker you notice you see a guy
and you're like oh that's one of my
patients right and you know that earlier
that week he had just tested positive
for like a couple STDs a couple let's
just say one than
Julian Julian's getting too scared let's
say you know for a fact he has an SD
tested positive but now he's talking to
your friend your friend is responding
they're flirting and they're on the
verge of going home together that's what
we call that's what we call Hippa versus
herpes okay and that Hippa is a true law
and you got to let that girl get herpes
for your own career you could be you
could be disbarred or whatever you call
it you could never work again you could
be kicked out of medicine if they find
out you told someone a patient's
information how would they even find out
though I guess that's true yeah you tell
your friend obviously I depends on the
SD let's suppose you know he has an
active breakout outbreak she'll find out
herself all my friends wouldn't hook up
until they got those STD test results
first who are your friends me oh me
you're right me
too but I'm drunk at a bar it's like
come on um Esther Andy have you ever
been to a bar but no one could see you
because you didn't you weren't tall
enough they just saw you the little tip
of your head
going was it a conscious choice you just
to to never drink that was just
something you knew you'd never do yeah
must be intimidating when like the beer
is as big as you but why there I've
always said there's like literally a
million reasons like there's not just
one like for example Britney Spears
didn't drink um and that turned out
great and I want to applaud her
um there's alcoholics in my family I've
also always had like a complicated
relationship with food where like one
cupcake is just never enough and so I've
always felt like that would apply to
alcohol for
me um and it did for weed because I was
literally a drug addict for two years on
weed um and I'll be back soon we'll be
back together soon I know it I feel
it
but yeah I I also question
like the fact that drinking is just I
always thought it was weird like
teenagers are just so excited to do it
and I don't know why like my question
for you guys is like why did you drink
it was so fun it was so so fun
everything's funny and stuff I was
thinking today about how disgusting I
find drinking I feel like I feel so
grossed out by it I feel so happy I
don't drink do you how about you I drink
rarely but when I do there there even
even though like I haven't done anything
bad let's like you that dread that you
feel when you wake up in the morning
you're like is are my nipples still
attached like who have I like you look
at who you've called who stole my nipple
rings yeah like all of these things that
dread you felt that I felt in
age very AA or gento of
you oh my God she gred like dark dark
dark dark yeah that's too dark she gred
anyways that feeling that dread that I
felt in my 20s cuz usually I was up to a
crazy amount of [__] I'd wake up
like oh my God who feel so guilty I
would just text sorry to everyone same
so that feeling even now when I'm
drinking responsibly at 38 I still wake
up with that feeling of dread and I hate
it like that fear that guilt even though
I've done nothing I I think my body or
my brain just remembers I just can't
even imagine like adding my life is so
out of control just with my own
personality it's like I quit drinking 14
years ago it's like it's confirmed
drinking was not the problem like it's
alcohol was just an added thing but it
was very like quitting drinking was
number one best thing I've ever done in
my entire life number number number one
I don't know where I would be like I
have no clue it would be bad though if I
the scary part about drinking is which
you probably were is you really fun
drunk I am a really fun happy Good Times
drunk it was hot too remember she was in
her little outfit when she was her
Halloween outfit her birthday oh yeah I
might bust that out again cuz that is so
good with the new legs
too I got C
implants um but I will say yeah I can't
believe I was I was watching this thing
on YouTube about this guy was going
through like always sunny and he was he
was going through each episode to like
track how um what to try to diagnose
like if um Dennis was a sociopath or
psychopath or what and it was funny it
was like interesting but he's like oh I
wrote this thing down wrong cuz I was
like drunk and in my head I was like I
this guy's just watching YouTube videos
or watching old Sunny videos Drunk by
himself like trying to figure out it
just I was like o I don't know I just
can't imagine just being at my house
like drinking the two other people that
I know who do not drink any alcohol are
not well as adults one of them has just
been diagnosed as a sociopath really he
got discharged from the military they
never drank or they never drank never
drank like a sip of alcohol TR right
isn't it like to what it is but he he's
he's a friend of mine but apparently
he's sociopathic he's not your friend
he's been trying to get you but the
second one is we'll bleep this out
but oh yeah there's I mean as also Dane
Cook and Donald Trump have never drank
there you go guys and Esther you're in a
cute group I know very cute group but it
it's like there's a lot of people who
don't drink because they had really bad
alcoholic family
and that's a little bit at play well I I
mean not my parents but
yeah also the other big thing is like
there was no alcohol in my
house my my parents never drank not
after I got in there so I think that's
another thing too and like what I would
do like raising kids is I I would not
ever want the kids to see Dave drinking
cuz I think when you see your parents do
something you're just like like oh
that's the culture that's what we do and
so like I think the fact that was just
never in the house never talked about I
never thought about it I never was like
I want to be a grownup and do that but I
wonder if um watching your parent have a
healthy relationship with alcohol is
actually better than seeing no alcohol
so then it's like you at least see it
being done in a way that's not like
crazy and then so when you are in
college or in high school and you're at
the parties you're like not like what
the hell is this maybe but don't we all
just basically didn't we all just agree
that like alcohol sucks and we don't
want to have it ever yeah so if it's a
parent here's what I'm concerned with
like if I'm raising a kid with a dad who
at the end of the day always cracks a
beer like that's a problem for me like
then it's like oh it's something just
dad does it or if it's Mom having a
glass of wine every day like they're
going to be like oh alcohol is just a
thing you do at the end of the day I'm
not down for that yeah I feel like my
dad used to have rum and cokes and he go
it has a we go can we have a sip and go
has a adult stuff in it so we couldn't
have it but he never was like waste like
maybe he was drunk like at part did that
not didn't that make you want it that we
couldn't have a sip of it a little bit
maybe yeah but I don't know I think if
people can just have like a couple of
drinks to wind down and stuff I don't
see anything wrong with it I personally
could never do that I have no interest
in that that sounds so boring I don't
see anything wrong with it either like
Dave is Dave is a perfect example to me
of someone who's like sometimes when
we're out has a glass of wine I'm like
that seems perfect also that what you
said is very accurate about like candy
cuz I have cousins who grew up in
households like with bowls of candy no
no candy and then I think that makes you
go crazy it's me really no candy no
candy no soda the places with the bowls
of cany go what's going on here but okay
when I was a nanny how is that a
possibility no no no this is what rich
people do when I was a Beverly Hills
nanny I walked in this kitchen they
tested you they drug tested me for sugar
they were like no they were just like is
she going to eat this and I did they
didn't want you to bang their husband so
they wanted to make sure you going to
stay nice and chubby literally like
those glass jars everywhere cookies
candy and I was like this could never
fly in the household I grew up I would
eat every single one of them and then
the mom was like I wake up in the middle
of the night to go eat them the mom was
like we have it out in abundance all the
time so that it's like
meaningless it value I know imagine
though they just had all those like shot
glass like trays and like liquor and
shot glasses you know when you like all
like drink them together I have friends
who are medical professionals and I
swear to God the only thing they feed
their kids are
funion funion that's all they freaking
eat and sometimes I'm like do they want
like rice or like are great they great
snack they're a fun game well why why do
they do that is that just all the kids
will eat yeah or maybe I just catch them
at the wrong time and they're just
having a day of indulgence but I'm have
you had a funion I love funion I
actually haven't do we have Funions here
by any chance I literally just had a bag
of them yeah we have to get you funions
ASAP okay funions are good they're so
there's got to be MSG all the things
that it's like could not taste better
could not be a better tasting you know
that's Chick-fil-A is MSG oh that's what
it is but MSG is not inherently bad for
you say more I mean I just learned this
from David Chang yeah you too I think
like tomato has a certain level of MSG
like naturally eat more and but I'm
personally sensitive to it um I so I
don't know if it's bad for me but I do
feel a little bit like MSG drunk
afterwards um my friend goes crazy we
would go to this one uh Chinese
restaurant in Santa Fe she would be
insane goes crazy she would be like like
she was tripping she'd be like laughing
you do get a high from it it's a weird
little buzz I was like are you fake I
was like are you faking this but it was
every time I was like you always know
though when something has m cheeks you
feel a little bit High she would tell me
yeah she would be like but her mom had
it too so I'm like I didn't even Emma
she was not pres what is it mono sodium
glutamate it's like a salt looking thing
right yeah it's like a powder and it's
just like a super flavorful really
flavorful if we just took like a taste
of it my mouth is watering time is lunch
getting here a spoon of it is good
or a spoon of it is good or like it has
to absorb the flavor it's in um no like
I we always just add it to like
everything right like a little bit what
have you tasted on your like does it do
is it like hik where it like takes in
the flavor of everything around it hikma
such a good Bland Bland thing delicious
yeah but it takes up whatever flavor you
put it in yeah I do like hi's a hia
that's why she absorbs everything around
her she's just a bland beautiful thing
crunchy wet it's so crunchy it's so good
in a burrito really good I know my dad
always gets no hik and I'm like bro
you're [__] grow up aren't you 80
grow
up grow a pair do you know what's so
messed up is like
I love yelling at my 80-year-old father
I'm like nothing makes me feel more
powerful than screaming full volume does
he stay like and like a weak man it's he
has like a he kind of has my voice your
dad is like a deeper voice there's like
a raspiness yeah and does he listen does
he what does he do when you yell at him
what's his reaction
usually now that he's 80 he just kind of
like I mean it's usually like not a
serious yell so it's more like he just
receives it and is like all right I
guess I [__] that up you know doesn't
say that things you yelled them for
specific things I can't like I can't
think of an example it is funny like in
my family my dad's fun you know how you
like yell at someone you love you're
like what the [__] is wrong with you
like that kind of thing and you know
they're so weak and fra they can't fight
back I feel you that's why I'm so mean
to you it's great what she tries to do
anything like an elderly
person I I do find comfort in that I
could do this to you for months I could
hold this stance in your forehead and
not get tired you could be trying your
hardest months six months I could hold
you like that I do find I yell at Roger
my stepdad the most and he has your dad
Vibes are they hard of hearing um he's
no
here's the thing about Roger that I take
advantage of you guys his memory is
going out so if we have a fight like a
bad one right now in an hour he won't
remember
it and he'll just come back into the
room like hey sweetie how are you you
hungry and so it's like I knowing that I
can just unload and unleash and he's
just like yelling at an old man that you
love is really fun I don't have this you
don't yell at your dad I love him so
much I'm obsessed with him we laugh we
cry part of the love wait speaking of
old people and laughing yell at him
speaking of old people and laughing and
crying he needs to get yelled at what
can we talk about the golden Bachelor oh
I am weeping thinking about it I'm
keyling I'm weeping I'm having every
emotion I should not have gone off
Lexapro like all the tears are flowing
at the Gold never felt the way I felt in
my life watching this doesn't he like no
no no okay do you want to yell at him
you do you do want to yell at him we
should send you in if I was his daughter
and I saw him dancing on the show I
would be screaming when he did the
cupcake thing I was worried about the
children it was hot that was hot okay
wait so have you seen it I I haven't
watched a single episode yet but I do
I've seen the cast can I just say no no
no get ready this is the most compelling
television to me the this and this is
sad what I'm about to say is really sad
the craziest thing is because he's like
an older handsome gentleman who's like
all glitzed up for all the ABC promo
stuff you expect him to be like this La
dick and then you hear his story and he
is like a little lamb of kindness and
love and you're like oh there's I'm just
like do you find yourself so Greatful
there's an example of a man like that on
our TVs I'm so happy for him I'm going
to get him his seis get him his blue Chu
get this man hard okay wait are they
showing um um
steamy been it's been it's so but but
the thing is it's soed up you guys you
know what it makes me feel it makes me
really excited to be 40 like I feel like
since I turned 40 I've been like do I
hate this or not it's like I'm seeing
all of these grown people feeling so
secure in who they are being so honest
and so like just fully themselves and it
was just like it made me me so like
honored and excited to be getting older
and just yes they were it's just like he
gave his like his um the first rose the
first impression Rose to this woman and
he's like he's like you know you make me
feel really
seen and he gives a turn he goes would
you like and she goes it would be an
absolute honor it's like so real the
connections they're having and then
they're so evolved as humans yes they've
just been through it and they're so
sweet and and they all are it's like we
see the the housewives which is fun but
that's like an egged on like 10
minutes the housewives but this is like
so different it's so wholesome there's
sorry I want to like it I want to all I
want we could help you one day I don't
watch I get my drama from like real
people I know she has been picking up my
facetimes a lot recently she didn't pick
them up yesterday I was so pissed wait
okay but then last night I called you
but Annie Annie
Annie the it makes the other Bachelor
stuff seem not real CU these people are
they're 12 years old they're they're
children it's nothing people in their
20s and 30 you don't know what you want
what you like you're nobody you don't
know your worth like these people know
their worth like this is like time is
running out I and also it's like let's
hurry up can he just pick the one he
likes and move on and just bring a new
one in like just bring a new one in
everyone needs somebody on the show if
they if these people
go wait even better so like you know how
after each season they have Bachelor in
Paradise oh I was thinking that they
need to have a Bach in Paradise oh my
God right they do a geriatric in
Paradise the ratings better be so good
this better be [__] the what did you say
Flor in Florida instead
of they're probably already
there they don't have to pay for airfare
but also it's like it's so funny to see
the facelift hotties like some are just
so hot and some are just regular yeah
like some are just
like a face lift is really a I'm not I'm
I really want to go
gently into the night I don't want to
get fa I don't know I look them a lot
but I do look at them every day I've not
even gotten Botox though I'm like baby
let's see how far we go let's go far
let's see how long we can go I'm not
against it let's see how low we can go
oh my God and like the L like
everything's just so sweet and he's
they're just so honest and there's just
so many gems in here like honestly I
didn't see one person I was like H I did
I did see one actually and she got sent
home oh she didn't get sent home the one
I saw mine was Matt's wife Matt's momit
so there are who what about the villains
are we going to have like a Karen like
is there going to be a villain show I
think so there's one woman who literally
did the ickiest move and I can't believe
she got to stay but she like in the
first episode she shows him a calendar
she made of herself oh I love that lady
no she's the faft one she did like a bud
she's like look at all these pictures of
me like imag her name is April right and
she said they're all April imagine
though you're on a date with someone and
they're showing you [__] pictures of
you see his wife he's never been around
a woman like this his wife was very
let's just say normal looking RP
beautiful wonderful person I'm sure but
that is like being a guy who asks you no
questions on a date oh actually which
leads me into the next show you told me
to watch that I watched last night no I
told you not is it possible I told you
not I said don't watch it I said it's
awful don't watch it it's PE PE it
should be called PE PE I think it's
called dating naked and it's on Max it's
not acceptable it's not okay these Brits
are crazy UK show it's been around a
long time I'm glad we left the British
people we're done with you no way cuz
love Island and UK I'm sorry absolutely
not love Island's got to go too just
because of how bad tell what it is I
know what it yeah go ahead Danny they no
it's not this no this is this has
something else going on this is you only
see people's genitals first you see them
genital first you see bot everything but
your face down they're like cuz you
never do this I'm like yes that's what
all of it is is people judging you on
your looks it should be it's like it's
the opposite of Love is Blind it's love
is balls look at and everyone's
disgusting by the way if you're seeing
just someone's genitals it's actually
disgusting 100% agree it's never not
been disgusting everyone's hideous you
need a face you can't even catch a Vibe
there's no vibe to be caught from made
me feel nice cuz it was like everybody
looks different and everybody looks
different
but look for cuz I've never I've never
sat across from somebody and said I
choose him because I think his dick
looks like this how about if you're the
person they're like oh I don't like that
vagina s it sent home and they're like
oh his balls are longer than a dick that
was horrible it's so bad and he was
doing tricks with his balls do you know
what so [__] up you see the genital
like confus CL they go close you don't
not see them you don't not see them it's
on max I don't know streaming is [__]
crazy man it's all you see and they keep
doing close-ups you know what is so sick
and weird ma is desperate this is
desperate go back to HBO what's wrong
with you I watched this with Dave and I
swear to God I've never seen Donut's
eyes glued to the TV she was like it was
like a little kid not supposed to be
watching but was watching like she
wanted to see the penises it was really
Randy barks at animals it' be funny if
He barked at all the penises like snakes
it's horrible Tod's like would you pick
me for my penis I was like I was like
I'd pick you just from your balls Todd I
mean it's so you need a face I don't
want anything to do with this it makes
me sick I know I told you I don't want
any it's like how dare they do this but
did you go far enough to know like oh
okay people are like I knew I picked
correctly just base on the ball to dicko
I could not get far the no it's bald
it's like it couldn't be less important
in the beginning of feeling A vibe than
what someone's crotch looks like and
then they're like judging women's tits
they're like oh her tits I know send her
home and then the woman is like she's
like a farmer she's like well you know
it's all out there they're all happy
they're like this is
great why are you happy it's wild why
are you happy it's wild why did you do
it and then they make the person that's
picking it naked it's so gross you know
what here's the way I would do this if
your face never gets shown ever if you
could do it fully Anonymous that would
be like the case for it cuz then it's
like who really cares but well except
for you and your feelings except the guy
with the elephant tattoo I thought you
were going to say elephantitis I was
like oh how big dick and he made it
elephant ears around theud is there any
world where you would go on a show like
this absolutely not tits alone I would
never be chosen today Bobby was like you
have like Salvador
Dolly but isn't there something to be
said for looking at a bunch of vaginas
in a case you wouldn't just to know
comparatively what yours looks like I
mean do that without
I've been comparing my vagina to vaginas
my whole life everything is normal
though Stella even if it was you know
all vaginas I mean I've seen the whole
scope and each one you know
looks special in their own
way right but the problem is that early
porn from the 80s and 90s specifically
chose women that had a an anatomy that
was very tucked in that never really
showed like a whole lot of labia and
they used to um in magazines they would
Photoshop the lebia out cuz they thought
it was too naked right so then girls
like us would be like oh that we must be
a little different because you know we
got some things hanging out of there it
made me me feel more accepted is what
I'm trying to say yeah which well not
the first episode of the girls they were
nice and
tight I was like are we only showing
these well they had to grab attention
somewhere you know what I mean well the
lips should grab
it okay I have a question
are there like known toxic traits that
people have you know they're toxic
they're bad but it's something you can't
help but you're still attracted
to cuz you we were saying like Caroline
was saying her Mark Mar was mean to her
and they'd go make out and like for me I
was one heckled by a comedian I never
met and I threw a drink in his face and
six months later he was my boyfriend
like what is going on what
so the negging works for you the
toxicity you when you're young and
stupid yes yes I know it's so
weird I'm trying that's why you like me
like when I nug you are there other
toxic traits that you're Cur name a few
toxic traits and see if I would let's
list toxic traits beer belly well I'm
definitely like patronizing [__] is dry
[__] is
dry yeah same well I don't someone
boastful [__] is dry oh
no Bragging yeah bragging
self-confidence so toxic self-confidence
what about like ghosting or taking a
while to text back disgusting oh I'm
soing wet I love that so much are you
serious yes I love Alo my biggest dry is
when someone has like a career or like a
profession like if someone says they are
an actor but they're not talented ruins
me oh you don't like that don't like it
it K that's kind of funny
you know I've dated some pretty unfunny
people what are some other toxic traits
like what are some things well LOF is
like so not a trait I would be attracted
to in fact like I was friends with this
guy and he started dating a girl he
really liked and he told me that he told
her no matter what if you text me I will
always get back to you in 15 minutes and
I was like hottest hottest I like that I
do like that as a healthy person I will
say this one guy he was aof all the time
but then he gave me so much attention so
it was like that's what you want it was
like oh I'm being chosen but then it
slowly once I gave it to him once he got
inside he just started taking it away
yeah I get an Nick if they respond
within 15 minutes to a text Stella what
is your problem I like someone that's
not thinking about me I don't know I
will say this when a guy is just like
when we're first starting to get to know
each other no pet names and he's just
like hi hello very Dr texting yeah um
where he's not showing me a whole lot of
uh like I don't know for sure like
certainty that maybe he likes me or not
I like that yeah it is the mystery
like I definitely think I was trapped in
like a young adult romance novel for a
lot of My Life um and I was always I
think my like core wound as a child was
I really wanted to feel chosen so I
would reject and want guys to push
through the rejection to to come for me
and it did not happen turns out guys
listen to you they actually aren't as
bad of listeners as you think when you
go I hooked up with this guy years ago I
was telling Todd about it and he was I'm
like why am I telling Todd this um but
there was this guy um that
I had an improv class with and we hooked
up and he was like oh yeah I'm going
through a breakup and I then I saw all
the girl stuff around and I realized it
was a recent
breakup like he had I'm like when did
you break up he's like yesterday I'm
like oh my God you're in a relationship
I was like so mad but then for like two
weeks we hooked up and then he's like my
ex-girlfriend wants to get together like
what should I do and I was like get back
with her whatever I probably punched him
I was like whatever dude and then I was
like devast you know then he got back
with her and then it was like five years
of torture there's one thing that I love
but I hate at the same time I don't love
a drunk but I like the smell of alcohol
and cigarettes on the M turn on I love
me too but I will never tell him that I
actually like the way he sounds he
smells like a just Rebellion no it's to
be it's like a frat guy beer breath Dave
knows like if I smell alcohol on your
breath I'm like it's so hot it's it's
really weird what about a spit like a
cigarette and then a spit oh I like that
there's a gum chew there's a type of a
gum chew that gets me every time we
talked about this no we've talked about
this
it's it's Ryan Gosling when he in the at
the VMAs with oh it's like there's a
chew at you it's like that's kind of
condescending it's like a little bit
like they're objectifying and chewing
their gum at you I get you but I think
okay so I think that this is like a a
fear of vulnerability and it's like
wanting these people wanting the the
like longing and the romance of it
rather than the reality of it because
the reality of it is scary and you have
to be present for it so I think that's
what that was for me I'm the same way
yeah okay there's one more thing that
I'm attracted to but Todd it's funny cuz
Tod was like obsessed with me and I was
like ew ew ew and then the pandemic came
in then I was like I I'm so happy I'm
not single no offense I don't I don't
love I don't love [__] boys but I like
guys who have are known to sleep around
I'm hit or miss with those but they as
long as they're like polite to the girls
not [__] boys because [__] boys are like
rude to women they don't call back ghost
but if a guy is known to have slept with
a lot of girls and it's girls not too
far away from my circle where they like
girls are like oh he's good in bed then
I'm like oh I like that that is toxic
it's a little bit it gives me I feel
threatened but I like the feeling of
feeling threatened well I've had it with
a guy with a girl with a guy where a
girl I didn't know he was like hooking
up with this other girl he had hooked up
with her previously and then I I like
hit her up and um I was like is he cool
like I just wanted to make sure he
wasn't going to like gossip about me or
tell people or whatever and then she was
like back with him and I didn't know
that and he was like playing both of us
um so to get me away from him because
she like was threatened by it because
she was pursuing him again she just told
me he was like really bad in bed and
that made me want to hook up with him
more CU I was like no way that the way
he is with one girl is how he is with
another girl like that didn't like that
actually made me more interested and
then was he was
he it
wasn't great oh so she wasn't lying I
don't but I think she was lying I think
they were a better match I think their
energies matched better and mine I was
way more like open and kind of like a
hippie like I was trying to really
connect that's really hard for me if the
situation you just described where you
know a girl that had a thing with him
already I'm like out right there I'm
like I oh to even know them oh to know
them personally I'm with you so I would
never you're saying never have sex with
a guy who an acquaintance has had sex
with just because I just don't like to
mix that it's it's hard to want to but
that's why I went to her because I
thought it would be like fine I also
lived in Santa I don't think there's
anything wrong with it I think I went to
Sant I lived in Santa Fe for so long and
it's such a small town that your best
friend's bang the guy that you are in
love with and you have to just like you
can't be mad at them because because
it's just so such a small and I think
when I was still dating with in comedy
it felt like that where it was like all
right there's not that I mean we're
going to overlap you know for sure in
comedy especially I personally don't
think there's anything wrong if like
there have been instances where um I've
seen friends male friends date exes of
their friends and marry them with kids
and it works out like I think that you
know you shouldn't have these really
like hard and fast rules about well my
friend's you know that's my friend's ex
so then now you're like [__] blocking
yourself possibly like a better match
when guys do it too to me it always
feels sorry to be like you know sexist
guys but it does feel like a little
misogynist cuz I have don't watch
anymore you don't have to apologize I
have guy friends who are like they're
like oh if if my friend [__] her like
she's gross like she's dirty like that's
not what I mean and I do think it is my
own toxic trait where like if I know
you've been with someone that I am
friends with and know I will just be so
insecure about it right like it's I not
confident enough or something yeah I'm
sure I could get over it but I always
had a thing with guys that like assumed
they could hook up with me I never
wanted to hook up with I didn't like
that power Dynamic of them like being
too cocky about it that's horrible what
a guy it just acts like he assumes he
can have you yeah like but I always
thought like when my older brother would
have parties or something and his
friends would come over and it was like
they just like thought they could hook
up with me and I was like and my older
brother would always be like try I dare
you he's like please try a watch and I
would be like because I was so mean to
them because I didn't like that they
felt like a yeah older more powerful
Vibe can I tell you guys something about
these
brooms they're not useless Filipino
brooms called
sting um they're made from like sticks
and they're probably the best brooms you
will ever ever use they kind of scrape
too my mom's biggest like meltdown in
America was over brooms cuz she was like
they don't have real brooms America
she's like how am I going to beat you
into swimming I know so we had to find
broom specifically from the Filipino
store and an Asian store for her to just
calm the [__] down because she likes to
clean a lot and she didn't have the
broom she wanted but those one Willis is
really good and then the other one
Willis thinking to the one in the the
Middle with just that one the best for
outdoors that one I like that that's
cute too that
one it and lay it on fire wait how is
that a broom that's a broom how though
it's outdoors takes out all the [__]
leaves everything do you sweep do I
sweep have you swept I have swept
recently I like vacuum cleaners do you
how vacuum I'm being real I have no clue
I do have a cordless and I have a corded
I'm actually in between vacuum cleaners
right now you know we should talk about
this which one the v15 animal I had the
meal m i e l e and it broke and it was
going to be too much money to fix it
like so we decided we just ordered a new
one fixing one is crazy that's what
you're warranty vacuums I thought were
like buy for life but this one we only
had for like that's like a Cutco scam
that's like when people would come by
and be like buy the Cutco knives like
Cutco knives this is like no vacuum
cleaners break you get rid of them and
not in my house we've had my mom has
been using the same vacuum cleaner since
like she lived in an apartment before my
dad did she get it fixed where did she
take it there are specific places to get
vacuums fixed I thought those were
fronts there's one next to my house I
legit thought that a vacuum clean like
scam for kids it's like buy my candy for
my basketball team get vacuum cleaner
the the vacuum cleaner repair shops are
why I thought I would have this one
vacuum forever but then when they call
and they say it's going to be $500 to
fix it I'm like keep it it's yours
now is that a scam maybe that's how they
collect them I don't know I don't know
but also my mom the way that she can
keep things forever
and they'll be just spotless that's a
generation thing it's a different are
you the dirtiest thing she has
yes I break everything I have all the
time and she keeps everything nothing's
put away nothing's nice nothing's clean
nothing's neat um well happy Halloween
guys we learned a lot about vacuums it
feels like five years ago our beautiful
Caroline was here oh I love her so much
I know she really is the most fun
absolutely love her it's like like she's
a fun big sister and she just as fun
baby it's just I would love to have a
sleepover at her house and get her hats
yes oh yeah that's so it's so funny to
be like can we come over can I sleep
over can I sleep can we come over and
not leave till the
morning um you guys thank you for
watching we love you we're so we're so
in love with the Slugs we love our
sluggy and grab some merch if you
haven't yet if it's still available and
we will always see you next week with a
brand new
episode don't watch that naked show
don't watch the naked show watch the
golden Bachelor watch it watch it all of
it it's so
[Music]
disgusting